toolbox if you like of measures that
they could pull out uh in order to try
and slow the rate of infections that
could be vaccine passports that could be
more mass squaring i'm sure there'll be
questions about that i'm not sure at the
moment that that's where the government
wants to go yet but certainly at this
press conference i have no doubt that
the journalists there will be asking
questions about what additional measures
some of the
scientific advisors
think that there might be needed just to
say who is going it will be jenny
harry's who is the now the leader of the
health and security agency stephen
powers who's the medical director of nhs
england and of course the health
secretary sajid javid
and beth in here now uh just coming past
uh five o'clock and it is uh the
newshour but uh much of the newshour
will be taken up with this news
conference with uh sajid javid beth
rigby is with me we might have a bit of
talking to do because i gather they're
running a little bit uh late they're
running a bit late yeah they don't have
a covered news conference for weeks and
then they're a bit late when they do but
um but you i mean interesting what you
were saying cases
you said 49 000 so above 40 000 then for
what is it the eighth day
in a row but the government's point
seems to be that you know when it comes
to hospitalizations and deaths um then
the situation
is pretty static at the moment certainly
you know compared with last month
yes look the government is i think
applying a wait-and-see or a watch and
weight approach uh a number 10
spokesperson saying today we've set out
our autumn and when to plan in terms of
plan a and plan b and we continue to
look at the latest scientific data there
isn't any proposed plan for any further
lockdowns we are sticking to the autumn
and winter plan we have set out but but
it might be worth raising two something
that
patrick valance
the chief scientific advisor said when
the government did set out that plan in
september uh he said at the time there
was a simple series of recommendations
which i've been pushing continuously and
continue to do so and this is the quick
bit the lesson is to go earlier than you
think you want to go a bit harder than
you think to want you want to and go a
bit broader than you think you want to
in terms of applying restrictions i'm
afraid that's a grim message but that is
what the evidence says and what i think
is beginning to emerge is that we have
certainly
medical practitioners we had matthew
taylor of the nsh nhs confederation uh
this morning saying that the overwhelm
evidence is that we do need to act so
you have a group saying look we think we
actually need
to bring in some measures now that we
need to get more stringent in terms of
trying to manage the virus the
government as i said i think adopting a
wait-and-see
approach and their approach will be
let's get the most vulnerable people
with those boosters that third
shot of vaccine
which they hope for the over 50s and the
more vulnerable will keep them out of
hospital will keep them better protected
in the winter and those in the medical
services some scientific advisors
perhaps
worried about what they can see coming
down the track and wanting to take some
pre-emptive measures now such as perhaps
face mask wearing or perhaps introducing
that covered vaccine status to get into
gigs or football matches or you know big
events so there's there's sort of as i
said a tool box of measures it doesn't
feel at the moment that the government
wants to start rolling them out but i
think pressure is growing to do so i
mean we can have a look i think at uh
you know to to build on what you were
saying about what um plan b is exactly
uh just stay with us beth and
under plan b the public will be told
clearly and urgently it says about the
need to exercise caution to help control
the virus with face coverings uh as beth
was saying once again becoming a legal
requirement in some settings it would
mean the work from home mandate
could be reintroduced and the government
would also have the option to make
coveted vaccine certificates
mandatory in those scenarios that uh
some of those scenarios that beth
was talking about well earlier the chief
executive of the nhs federation told sky
news that
action must be taken immediately
what's frustrating is that the
government has said that it is the
pressure on the health service that will
be the determinant of whether or not
they act i speak to health leaders every
day in every part of the service
ambulance services mental health
services the acute sector i haven't
spoken to a single one who doesn't say
that they are incredibly stretched it's
only going to get worse so the
government needs to it needs to act on
its promise and its promise is to try to
protect the nhs from becoming
overwhelmed and that's where we need to
act now in order to head off that and if
we don't
i'm afraid we will once again and we
have been here before we will stumble
into a crisis
right that's the nhs confederation let's
listen to what kwazii quarten was saying
uh earlier on sky news the
conversation about restrictions on
travel restrictions on you know more
lockdowns is completely unhelpful i
think we've
had a huge job of work getting the
vaccine rollout to the point that we
could reopen the economy that was the
main thing we were focused on this year
that has worked and what we want to do
is manage
the situation as it is we don't want to
go back into lockdown or into further
restrictions um stephen reicher who as
you know is a member of sage uh is
advocating plan c and saying that we
can't rule out another lockdown no i i
would rule that out
let's go back to beth ruby so i mean
it's interesting isn't it i assume
politically they don't want to go
anywhere near another lockdown
no it's very clear that they don't want
to go near another lockdown the economy
is coming back
the furlough scheme
is winding down and the government
really do want to get a front foot and
look forward
and keep the economy
reopening and try and allow people to
live as normal lives as possible but as
i said there is that a
series of measures that could be
introduced and in different countries
they do it slightly differently when i
went over for example to new york uh
with the prime minister for the united
nations general assembly you couldn't go
into a coffee shop and and get a coffee
uh in new york in the us and new york uh
with without showing your covered
vaccination certification now the
government do have these options that
they can introduce
but they don't want to go there but i
was talking to a cabinet minister at
tory party conference a few weeks ago a
couple of weeks ago and when i said
what's the biggest risk going into the
winter
they replied it was covered because
there was an unpredictability about how
the virus might behave
over the winter there's uncertainty
whether there might become a new strain
of the variant and it is quite
unpredictable at the moment we have high
case numbers uh and we have but we have
quite stable hospital numbers but that
is all the data that the government will
be looking at obviously in scotland what
you've seen is that there was a peak
when children went back to school it's
beginning to drop off in infection rates
we've got half term coming up so there's
a little natural circuit breaker there
in terms of uh the children all being
off school for for 10 days or away from
each other for 10 days but the
government as i said is a wait and see
approach but but quasi quatern sort of
ruling out a lockdown completely there
it's obviously absolutely the last thing
that the government would do but i'm not
sure the prime minister would
emphatically be able to rule it out
because if you had for example a new
variant and you're in a position that
we're in
in december last year
it might not be as easy to just
completely say no to doing that but
absolutely
that is something that the government
would 100 not want to do
and the real concern
here is that still
um half i'm just seeing of 80 year olds
have not had this booster jab so downing
street saying today that uh vaccination
and the roll out of a vaccine had broken
this link between cases and hospital
administer admissions and deaths but
that relies now on the booster programme
being stepped up doesn't it absolutely
and that's why i was saying at the the
beginning of uh talking about what they
might talk about today that that chris
witty uh tweet talking about trying to
get people to go and get those boosters
rolling out the boost to communicate in
that pressing upon the public the need
to go and get that extra protection if
you're over 50 if you're in vulnerable
age groups is going to be critical
going into the winter and i'll be
interested to hear what they say about
that are they going to make it more
readily available
roll it out to more places have dropping
centers are they going to talk more
about other antiviral drugs that the nhs
is buying up in order to try and limit
the effect of of covert if you get it
because one of the great things of the
vaccine as we all know is that even if
you do get covered
the chances of you having to go to
hospital becoming really ill are much
lessened
by having that double dose of the
vaccine so there will be a big public
public information push i think in the
coming weeks to try and get people to
get those boosters and also have that
vaccination if they haven't and in
schools now at 12 to 15 year olds
there's a big push to try and get the
the younger
people uh vaccinated too
and there's some more detail
uh beth just coming in on antiviral
drugs that the um government have
acquired and we're going to hear more of
i'm sure
more about rather from sajid javid and
britain says that the government says it
secured 250 000 courses of pfizer's oral
antiviral
covid 19
drug and the government says that the
antivirals need authorization from the
medicine regulator but could be in
use by
the end of this year they've also bought
450
480 000 uh courses of another antiviral
drug so clearly uh that will be
something that uh javid will want to
talk about yeah i'm just having i've
actually got that statement here i'm
just having a look at that yes they're
saying here that they've got two new
antiviral
drugs that they have brought up and
they're expected to be given to those
most at risk of the virus and the
government's saying that that will help
reduce the severity of symptoms and ease
the pressure on the nhs over
the winter this health secretary i think
will say in this press conference that
this is a new defense in our arsenal
with two new anti-viral drugs that the
government have
secured so again another
line of defense for the government but
but it will not want to detract in this
press conference about really trying to
get elderly people to go and get that
booster because there are concerns that
the
effectiveness of that double dose
vaccine begins to wear off so what they
really need is for the over 80s
particularly but but everyone over 50 to
go and get those boosters to give them
that protection as we go into the winter
right and they seem to be saying that
the the booster
supply booster vaccine supply is not the
problem it's uh that more people have to
come forward and as i speak uh beth
sergio javid is about to begin
good afternoon and welcome to dining
street for today's coronavirus briefing
i'm joined by dr jenny harris the chief
executive of the uk health security
agency and by professor steve powers the
medical director of nhs england
we've always known that the winter
months would pose the greatest threat to
our road to recovery the darker skies
the colder weather provide perfect
conditions
not just for covered 19 to thrive but
for other seasonal viruses too like flu
and norovirus
and ahead of winter just as we expected
we're starting to see this impact
cases are rising
and yesterday we reported 43
738 new cases across the uk
up 16 percent from the previous week
and they could go yet as high as a
hundred thousand a day
we're also seeing greater pressure on
the nhs
across the uk
we're now approaching 1 000
hospitalizations per day
the nhs is performing with distinction
and i'd like to thank everyone who's
working so hard to keep us safe
and we'll do what it takes to make sure
that this pressure doesn't become
unsustainable and that we don't allow
the nhs to become overwhelmed
deaths remain mercifully low
but they are still sadly over 100 a day
this pandemic is not over
thanks to the vaccination program
yes the the link between cases and
hospitalizations and deaths has
significantly weakened
but it's not broken
so we must all remember
that this virus will be with us for the
long term
and that it remains a threat
a threat to our loved ones
and a threat to the progress that we've
made in getting our nation closer to
normal life
we're looking closely at the data
and we won't be implementing our plan b
of contingency measures at this point
but we'll be staying vigilant preparing
for all eventualities while
strengthening our vital defenses that
can help us fight back against this
virus
and today
as we approach this critical time for
our nation's recovery i wanted to bring
you up to date with some of the work
that we're doing to strengthen these
defenses as we learn to live with the
virus
one line of defense is treatments
and i have some positive news to share
today
we should all be proud that the uk has
been at the forefront of some of the
most cutting-edge treatments
covered 19 treatments have already had
an amazing impact
and they are especially important for
people who can't take vaccine for
medical reasons or if they are
immunocompromised
it was british scientists who led the
clinical trial that discovered
dexamethasone
that can be an effective treatment for
covert 19 and it's already estimated to
have saved some 1 million lives across
the world
and some of the most vulnerable nhs
patients in hospital are already
benefiting from rhonaprov a treatment of
monoclonal antibodies that were
specifically designed to treat covid19
we're also seeing some promising
developments around antivirals too
you see antivirals work by targeting a
virus at an early stage
and disrupting the way the virus
develops and multiplies
i'm pleased to announce that we have
signed two landmark deals
securing hundreds of thousands of doses
of two new antivirals from pfizer
and from merck sharp dome
these antivirals have the potential to
speed up recovery time and to stop
infections from progressing
if these treatments get mhra approval
then we can provide some of the most
vulnerable patients with vital
protection this summer
and i want to deploy them as quickly as
possible
i'd like to thank everyone that's been
involved in this especially the
anti-virus task force under the
leadership of eddie gray for everything
that they've done to make this happen
and we'll keep working to secure even
more of these incredible treatments so
that we can continue to protect as many
people as possible
this is great news
but we cannot be complacent
when covid19 remains such a potent
threat
ever since our phenomenal vaccine
program began last winter
we've been in a race
a race between the vaccine
and the virus
and although we're ahead in that race
the gap is narrowing
we've come so far thanks to the efforts
of so many but with winter ahead
we can't blow it now
so we're going to do everything we can
to maintain our lead by strengthening
our vaccination program as our primary
line of defense
first
we'll redouble our efforts to encourage
anyone who's eligible
to take up the initial offer of a jab
there's almost 5 million people over the
age of 16 that remain unvaccinated in
the uk
it might be someone you know a friend a
family member a colleague
and if you do tell them
that it's never too late to come forward
so if you yet haven't had your job
please take this huge step
to protect yourself and to protect your
loved ones
second
we've extended the offer of a vaccine to
more and more people including young
people aged between 12 and 15 years
and we'll be making it easier for them
to get protected by opening up our
national booking service so they can get
their job at a vaccination centers
across the country as well as at school
third
we've also started rolling out our
booster program
which is vital to keeping us safe over
the coming months
because although our vaccines offer
powerful protection
we now know that the protection that you
get from a coveted vaccine reduces
materially over time
especially in older people who are the
greatest risk
and without delivering a top-up of
protection through a booster dose
we will see a real-world impact
as well as this
covered 19 mutates like any virus
and we're identifying new variants all
the time
this includes a new version of the delta
variant which is currently known as ay
4.2
and that new variant is now spreading
and while there's no reason to believe
at this point that ay 4.2 poses a
greater threat
the next variant
or the one after that
might do
so
we need to be ready
for what lies around the corner
this means our ongoing program of
booster jabs is so important and this
winter
we're prioritizing those most in need
today
we've reached a milestone of four
million top-up jobs in england
but we need to get even more people
protected
we've got the jabs
we just need the arms to put them in
if you've got 50 if you're over 50 or in
another priority group
and had your second job over six months
ago you're eligible for a booster
and the nhs will send you an invite
if you haven't been invited within a
week of reaching that six-month
milestone then please
get on to the national booking service
and book online
or phone 119
not just to save lives
but to keep your freedoms too
because all of these precious moments
that we've been able to restore over the
past few months the loved ones that
we've been able to see and the
collective experiences that we've been
able to share
they've been possible
thanks to our vaccination program
and because of so many of you that came
forward when it was your time
and if we want to secure these freedoms
for the long term
then the best thing that we can do is
come forward once again when that moment
comes
after the decisive steps that we've
taken this year
none of us want to go backwards now
so we must all play our part in this
national mission
and think about what we can do to make a
difference
that means
getting the jab
when the time comes
whether it's for covert 19 or flu
but although vaccinations are our
primary form of defense
there are many more things that we can
all do
to help contain the spread of this virus
like
you know meeting outdoors where it's
possible and if you can only meet
indoors letting in fresh air like
wearing a face covering in crowded
enclosed spaces especially if you're
coming into contact with people that you
don't normally meet and like making and
taking rapid tests that are making them
as part of your weekly routine
a quarter of the positive cases that we
are now identifying
come from those lateral flow tests
that people are taking without symptoms
but they're taking them as a precaution
especially if they're about to go and
meet a loved one perhaps a grandparent
or another vulnerable person
with winter soon upon us
these little steps
make a big difference
and they're more important now than they
have ever been
if we all play our part
then we can give ourselves the best
possible chance in this race
get through this winter
and enjoy christmas with our loved ones
thank you
i'd now like to hand over to to jenny
who will take us through some of the
latest covered 19 data
thank you thank you secretary of state
could i have the first slide please
um so i think what i'm going to do is
just highlight where we are in the
epidemiological picture today but also
highlight some of those successes from
the vaccination but also some of the
risks that lay ahead of us this winter
and the first slide is showing us the
number of individuals who've had at
least one positive covid19 test result
this is right across the uk and brings
us up to uh the 20th of october
and what we can see there is that the uh
since yesterday we have had 49
139 people tested positive now the
number here the 45 799 is our average
through the week which is entirely
appropriate we get dips and and peaks
but if i just go back one week to uh to
the 13th of october the number then was
42
776. so what you will see is there's
quite a steep increase as we go forward
uh in the number of cases
and i'd just like to flag on this the
unusual uh and and slightly worrying
picture
of the shape of that curve what we can
see is that the cases now are almost as
high as they were in july and actually
not far off where they were last winter
what we are not seeing is that dipped
down again at the other side of the peak
and that is really important because we
are kicking off the winter at a really
high level of cases
fortunately that is not currently
working through into a serious disease
and deaths but we will come on to that
in a moment
so could i have the next slide please
so this slide shows the number of people
in hospital with covert 19 again right
across the uk
and this has increased by 10.3 percent
since last week so again we are seeing
that movement forward um we would expect
a high point after rising cases to come
about two weeks after a peak and again
if you look at the the bottom on the
right hand side you can see where the
cases peaked uh previously in july uh in
middle of august you can see that
there's a peak there again what hasn't
happened is those cases have not
decreased they've continued at a fairly
high level
and in actual fact in the last few days
they are continuing to increase so on we
had
781 people
in hospital on the 19th of october again
if we go back a week only just over 7000
7057
so again a steady increase at the moment
and this is as we approach the winter
months and if we just compare if we go
back to hospital uh in in january the
peak then was around 39 200
so we can see we're a long way off that
but it's a very different
epidemiological picture
next slide please
and then sadly we look at the death so
we know that there was a very high uh
death toll uh in the first wave of the
pandemic and the total deaths uh which
we've sadly recorded since the start of
the pandemic are now just over 139 000
and these relate to uh people who've had
a positive code covid test within 28
days
of death
uh again what we can see here is the
most recent seven day average is 136
deaths it's very flat compared with the
first wave but it's clearly every every
life is of significance and i think one
of the more significant points about
this is uh we have had in the last two
days the highest rates we've had for
some time so just in the last 24 hours
179 deaths recorded so again these are
moving in the wrong direction we can see
the effect the really strong effect of
vaccination which is difficult to
believe just wasn't here this time last
year but still moving in the wrong
direction
next slide please
and then this is why we see that
difference we have had um a
huge roll out of vaccination this chart
shows the cumulative uptake of
individuals who've received their first
dose that's uh in blue and then who've
received two doses that's in orange um
and in total uh over 49 and a half in
million individuals have received that
first dose and over 45 a million the
second so we now have in the uh 12 plus
age group right the way through
adulthood uh 86.1 percent of our
population have had that first dose and
79
the second dose but clearly from the
information that we've had before the
fact that we're now approaching winter
and the fact as the secretary of state
has said there are still people out
there who have not had a first dose
which will significantly protect them
there's still plenty of opportunity to
come and get that
and if we look on the next slide
which shows us how the booster
vaccination program is going so these
are the vulnerable groups that's the
elderly
individuals and care homes those with
underlying conditions and you can see
here that we have reached over four
million individuals having their booster
dose
and i know professor powers can can add
some detail to that as we go forward now
this is for england only data um and um
it's increased from 860 000 on the 30th
of september so that is rolling out very
rapidly now as we
move forward to cover all of those at
higher risk
um and then on the final slide
i just want to highlight how important
that vaccination is what we can see here
are covered 19 cases coming into
emergency care within 28 days of a
positive test
and these are individuals where that
hospital
interventions uh resulted in an
impatient admission so these are people
who have had to seek care and what you
can see is in terms of vaccination
status the the dark blue lines are those
individuals who are unvaccinated
and the orange lines are those people
who have had two doses
and i think there is it's clear that as
you get more elderly you have a number
of other conditions um and but even then
the protection that is afforded to the
older people is significant but for
younger people i think there is a really
important message here which is you have
very very little risk if you have two
doses of vaccine but you have a
significant risk if you have had none at
that point i'll hand back to the
secretary of state
thank you very much jenny
so we're now going to take some
questions and the first two questions
are from members of the public and i
believe the first one
is from ruth who is in cornwall
so i just read the question with the
huge rise in covet infections would it
not be sensible to make wearing face
coverings mandatory in public buildings
again
so if i
start to answer that
that
we've set out a a clear plan a a few
weeks ago when we
took the step four decision back in july
and
we still feel absolutely the right
decision to start to learn
to live with this virus
and a lot of mandatory measures then
were put into guidance
and
it's asking people to take more
responsibility
to you to follow that guidance
and when it comes to face coverings as
i've just said a few minutes ago is that
you know everyone should
you follow that guidance
and think about others around them and
in the settings and if they are in a
closed space especially with people that
they are not normally with then they
should wear face masks if they're on
public transport new london underground
for example which has a face mask rule
they should uh observe those rules and
and then just finally to say to ruth
that we have also uh said uh that if we
need to take further measures as part of
our contingency plans plan b
they would include making face max
mandatory in in certain settings and
that may well include public buildings
if i can then the next question is i
believe from jonathan from leicester
the question is
many children 11 to 16 years have
contracted and recovered from covid
prior to their offer of a vaccination
what is the government going to do to
provide them and their families with
proof of recovery so they can travel
abroad for the forthcoming half term
break
so
what i would say to jonathan is that
first in in many countries not all but
in many countries
where they have a vaccination rule for
entry uh or even for um
if it's traveled by by plane uh for when
you're prior to boarding uh that they
would treat anyone under the age of 16
16 or under as being fully vaccinated as
the as the uk uh does that doesn't apply
as a as jonathan i think is also
alluding to to to every single country
uh so we are working on a plan uh that
would allow to for from our end to give
some kind of proof of uh antibodies but
it will ultimately be up to the country
that that uh child with with his or her
family is traveling to to decide whether
they can accept that and it is something
that as we've done with vaccinations we
work with our international partners to
try to come to a common understanding
my thanks to ruth and jonathan for their
questions
the
now from uh the the journalists thank
you all uh for coming and the first
person that i've got on the list is
sophie from bbc news
it's a question for the secretary of
state um nhs organizations have said
today they are right at the edge of what
they can manage now and given that your
own measure uh is unsustainable pressure
on the nhs in order to bring in
restrictions isn't it time to do so
also a question for professor powers do
you believe these nhs organizations when
they say they are right at the edge is
this not unsustainable pressure
thanks sophie let me start to answer
that that first of all i think you're
referring to the nhs confederation i've
got a lot of time for the nhs
confederation
i've met with them in the past and i
will do
in the future and they do a lot of good
work
on this particular question
we don't believe that the the pressures
that are currently faced by the nhs are
unsustainable uh don't get me wrong
there are huge pressures especially in a
e in primary care for example as well
but
at this point we don't believe they're
unsustainable and steve can answer a bit
more about that in a moment but i will
say one of the reasons
i think the the nhs is is able to do
what it does still um
number one is obviously thanks to
everyone that's working in the nhs but
the extra support where we're providing
uh this year for the second half of this
year we're providing an additional 5.4
billion pounds
which is certainly helping and that's
and that's what we hear and we will
absolutely keep it under review if we
feel at any point it's becoming
unsustainable then the the the
department together with our friends at
the nhs we won't hesitate to act
steve
yes thank you sophie so i think the
first thing to acknowledge as the
secretary of state has said and indeed
as our chief executive amanda pritchard
said at the health select committee
yesterday the nhs is under considerable
pressure we've had a very tough summer
as we have continued to treat people
with covid being admitted to hospitals a
society has opened up again and we've
begun to see a return to normal near
normal levels of presentations of urgent
and emergent people who need urgent
emergency care and of course as we
started to make inroads uh into
treatments for patients whose care has
been disrupted and delayed during the
pandemic so so it undoubtedly feels
exceptionally busy
in the nhs and our nhs organizations are
telling us that all the time now in
september we saw a reduction in the
number of covered patients in hospital
down to below 5000 in england as
infection rates went down as jenny
showed you earlier
in the last few weeks those infection
rates have gone back up again and we
have started to see again as secretary
of state has said an increase in number
of emissions and an increase in the
number of patients in hospitals so now
in england in our main hospitals we're
just over six thousand
as i stand here today six thousand
patients with covid which is back to
where we were in the middle of september
uh and i anticipate that over the next
week or two that number will increase
because infection rates are increasing
and as i've said many times there is a
lag between infection rates and hospital
admissions
now
it's not just covet of course
we
have one eye to the flu season
and we don't know what's going to happen
with flu this year but there is a risk
that we will get more flu back and it
will be worse than previous years
because we missed out a season last year
and there are other viruses uh around us
yet as well around as well and of course
we are continuing to do all that work
around
the recovery of our elective and routine
services so it is very very busy indeed
we
work very closely with the department of
health social care
around the judgment of how the nhs is
doing and we will continue to do that as
we go into winter but i think the really
critical thing is that the public can
help us here the public can absolutely
help the nhs here and as the secretary
of state said there are things that the
public can do
that will take the pressure off the nhs
so the first is to remember that for
face masks there is guidance in place if
you are in a crowded environment a high
risk environment on the tube you know a
building cramp building with with low
ventilation then wear that face mask it
makes a difference it really does and
the second thing of course is the
vaccine program because the vaccine
program is our best protection against
covid and therefore
if you've been invited for a booster and
you haven't had one or if you are
getting your invitation in the next few
weeks then get that booster as quickly
as possible because we know that the
immunity that we get from vaccines will
drop off over time and we don't want
that to occur going into winter so this
is not something
that we
that we just need to leave we can get
the public to help us on this and and
during the last 18 months the pandemic i
think the public has been fantastic in
responding to assist us in the nhs with
pressures and and the public can do it
again by remembering covet is still here
we need to be cautious where appropriate
and we need to get those jabs
when we're offered them
thank you steve
next romney from itv
secretary of state new cases today are
only just under thousand you just said
yourself they could go as high as a
hundred thousand today
aren't you in danger of ignoring the
main lesson from the pandemic so far
which is
if you don't if you ignore the warning
signs when they're flashing and you
don't take action then you have to take
harsher action further down the line and
to professor powers by may are you
concerned about waning vaccine uh
immunity and are you already seeing an
increase in the number of double-jabbed
people being hospitalised
thank you
i think that you know the plan that
we've set out is uh
taking absolutely into account the the
situation we're confronted with at the
moment and
and
in my remarks
the entire focus is on you know what we
can do to help ourselves
we obviously the government's got a huge
role to play the vaccine program the
testing program
but we need people to take up those
vaccines when they're offered especially
uh the boosters
and uh the the testing regime and you
know the state that stays in place the
offer of the free test for example as i
was saying that is so important
identifying positive cases the action
then people take if they are positive to
to isolate and and not spread that virus
any further and the behaviors that we've
talked about that we can all uh deploy
and and we've set out that that's our
sort of plan a what we've called plan a
we do have contingency measures uh radio
won't go through the wall now but
they're publicly available and we've set
out that what we would do if the
situation became more challenging and so
we're not at that point yet and uh what
i hope is that uh everyone can can play
their part especially when it comes to
the vaccinations especially when it
comes to the booster if you are invited
or if you're at that six-month milestone
please get your boost
well i think we're all concerned about
waning of immunity but i think the first
thing to say is to remind everybody that
vaccines are incredibly effective if you
wind back a year ago
i think if you had said that we would
have a vaccine program rolled out to as
many people as we had uh which has a 95
percent or thereabouts effectiveness of
preventing hospital admission uh i think
we would have been absolutely delighted
so don't forget that vaccines are
incredibly effective and are giving a
high level of protection and that is why
for similar infection rates we are not
seeing the numbers of people in hospital
that we saw in previous peaks but it's
an actual phenomenon that
immunity
reduces over time after a vaccine after
a natural infection that's why people
get repeated flu infections over the
course of their lifetime so this is a
natural phenomenon it will occur
and that's exactly why jcvi have
recommended that a booster dose is an
important part of our armament
against this virus in boosting immunity
particularly as we go into this winter
so yes waning
of immunity will occur
but we have a way of dealing with that
and that is the booster program and
therefore once again to remind everybody
uh that getting that booster when you
were offered it uh when you're eligible
six months after your second dose is
really critical this pandemic is not
over yet uh and increasing the level of
immunity that we have in the population
by that booster is one of our main
defenses going into the winter along
with the caution
that we've described in terms of people
being sensible particularly in higher
risk environments and then the final
thing i should have said earlier i'll
say now is don't forget your flu vaccine
because i said you know flu is likely to
come back this winter
last year we had our most successful
ever flu vaccine program in the nhs we
didn't have any flu this year it needs
to be even better so
jab for covered
jab for flu
be cautious that's our message going
into winter
thank you
next uh thomas from sky
secretary of state some people may see
it as complacent that you see nothing in
the data at the moment to give you any
calls for concern
particularly when you've got people like
the nhs confederation and many senior
scientists arguing that all the warning
signs are there give us a number how bad
do hospital admissions need to get per
day before you do bring in plan b
and can i ask you a question also on on
the antivirals there will be many people
who with me weakened immune systems now
who are very concerned about the surge
hopeful that these drugs might be there
for them
will they be
the
first part of your question that we are
concerned i think everyone is right to
be concerned and
and i hope that you i've managed to
just in the last sort of 10 minutes so
express
that that concern that we have and the
reasons why we do with the cases rising
as jenny has just shown in some of the
latest data as well uh deaths i said are
still mostly low but they're still more
than 100
and
the
the focus though you're very much
remains on what we set out in in plan a
you know those vaccines that they are
working uh they are as you know steve
has just alluded to we've seen from the
data if you look at the hospital
admissions as well uh the the vaccines
are clearly working we estimate the the
ons estimates that they've saved some
130 000 lives they've prevented some 240
000 people from being hospitalized
they've prevented some 24 million
infections that's what the vaccines are
doing so if more people get vaccinated
including by the way just to emphasize
again the 5 million or so across the uk
that haven't even had their first jab
and that's why i said if you know
someone please appeal to them speak to
your friends your relatives and just
really sort of nudge them and say please
you know do your bid to help yourself
and help others
and if they've got some
weird ideas about vaccines because
they've been reading misinformation on
the internet and elsewhere then point
them in the right direction but the the
vaccines are absolutely key and as
steve's also said the flu vaccine this
year is is more important than ever it's
our biggest flu vaccination program in
history i think some 35 million uh doses
uh that we've got and then the people
together that we're targeting uh with
that to really help uh your combat both
those uh viruses so you that's our plan
we remain cautious and there's no and
you ask me
what's the number of um
hospitalizations that we we monitor this
daily we work very closely obviously the
department with the nhs on a daily basis
and it's not just one particular
number that we're looking at and i'm
very conscious that behind these numbers
you often talk about numbers easily but
there's a person there's an individual
there's a family that's being affected
we're very conscious
of that but as well as hospitalizations
we're looking at the pressure on the nhs
across the board and a e on primary care
on emergency
services such as others the 999 the
ambulance services so we're looking at a
a number of factors and and taking them
all into account on the the drugs the
the new antivirals and we've
the i can tell you a bit more about them
that we've in terms of the total that we
put is 730
000 courses patient courses we've pub
that we've purchased that's 480 000
courses of the merc
that i referred to and then 250 000 uh
from pfizer it's important also i think
to say they they have they work
differently they're different mechanisms
so
it could be one or the other that might
be deployed in some cases it might be uh
both they're both
all and they can be deployed
either if someone has fallen ill um or
if um you know from covert or if uh if
if you expect uh that they might do
because there's an outbreak let's say in
a care home you know where you would
actually have uh vulnerable uh people uh
it's a really new sort of fresh tool in
our armor these are the first antivirals
ever that are designed specifically here
for for covid um they still need to get
approval from the mhra the the tests
that are publicly available at the
moment have been very encouraging uh but
we wanted to get there in uh early and
sign a deal so that we could be one of
the first countries in the world uh to
receive them should they be approved by
our regulator as safe and uh effective
steve did you want to add today yes well
i think as the secretary of state has
said there is no one number uh that we
would use to think about triggering
further interventions because it is more
complex than that there is a variety of
things that we look at so we talked
about infection rates because they tell
us what's likely to happen in the nhs in
the next few weeks we've talked about
vaccine effectiveness because that tells
us
how many people are likely to require
hospitalization
and
we look at obviously the number of
emissions but we also look at what's
happening with flu and other viruses and
what's happening with other emergency
admissions
so there's a variety of things that we
will be looking at and continue to look
at of course the final thing to say is
that we do see geographical variation so
what's happening in one part of the
country might not be happening in
another part of the country that's been
typical of the pandemic over the last 18
months
and it's possible that we will see that
variation again so so there is no one
number to look at we have to look at
things in the round uh look at all these
numbers use judgement and of course work
closely with colleagues in uk hsa on the
public health side the department of
health social care to take a collective
judgment and on the antivirals it is
indeed great news um i mean as the
secretary of state has said
we over the last 18 months i think one
of the things that has been
most impressive about the response of
the nhs is the ability
to stand up drugs rapidly to investigate
drugs and to work out which drugs are
truly effective at managing this
pandemic and that has undoubtedly saved
many lives in the uk but actually
throughout the world and i think we
should be really proud that a public
health system uh healthcare system uh
such as ours is very well placed to do
that sort of study and we've shown that
we can we can do it so we have these new
uh anti-virals coming on stream on the
pirivia is likely to be the first one in
terms of who should get it clearly that
is a little bit dependent on the mhra
who need to license it and they will
license it with
their particular licensing conditions
we will of course be taking advice from
clinical experts as to who it is most
appropriate but in general we would want
to target these drugs as we have done in
the past at those at the highest risk
of infection and the highest risk of
hospitalization because that is what we
are most trying to avoid of course death
and so yes i think it is likely that
individuals with weakened immune systems
are likely to be on that list that our
clinical experts would recommend but
let's wait until we get the mhra
licensing and let's wait until we get
the advice of our clinical experts
thanks steve uh kate from the sun
secretary of state you have seen today
that the sun's launched a new campaign
to urge brits to get their booster jabs
i wonder do you want to see a sort of
return to that blitz spirit we saw in
the first vaccine program and people
were proud to get their jab posting
pictures of it
and more concretely are we going to see
a return to things like pop-up clinics
maybe a dad's army of retired medics
enlist the military to sort of help us
turbocharge that jabs roll out
and to the medics um some gps are saying
they're too busy to roll out the booster
jazz this is just not a high enough
priority are they wrong and what would
you say to them today
thanks kate the i mean yes in short yes
uh and thanks to the sun uh for its
campaign and and others that are getting
behind this that that the boosters they
really could not be more important uh
yeah as i've said that we have we've
just as a country we've come such a long
way we've got so much to be proud of for
the scientists that designed the
vaccines the the the the nhs and all the
volunteers that delivered the vaccines
and look where it's got us look where we
are today versus just not even a year
ago the start of this year look how it's
changed our daily lives and we all want
to keep that we want to sustain that and
the biggest difference is the vaccines
and and it cannot be stressed enough how
important it is to first get your
initial vaccine if you're one of the
five million that haven't but if you are
the millions that did you know the 95
million jabs that we we gave if you're
one of the recipients of those that
we know your immunity wanes we're
particularly concerned about those over
the age of 50 and it's been six months
since their second job and they really
need to to get the boost and it's great
that so many people are coming forward
but we need more more people to come
forward as their six-month milestone uh
comes together and and yes we will be
as well obviously this in the
vaccination centers it's gps they're
going out there and delivering them in
care homes and
other places they're making home visits
for those that that need it there will
be the pop-up uh your centers
vaccination centers the mobile units
we're going to deploy everything and it
is and i think you use the right is it a
blitz spirit it is we need to sustain
the progress that we've made we could
lose it we really could lose that
progress if people don't take up their
vaccination offers and uh yeah i really
couldn't emphasize it more if i may just
say this again it's important to flu if
you're eligible for the flu vaccine this
year we expect there to be a lot more
flu around than normal why because last
year there just wasn't much because of
the measures we've taken over covid
there wasn't much circulating and also
they want the usual number of samples to
make the flu vaccine and so you take
that together your flu could be a real
problem this winter but we can all do
something about that that's the good
news and that is get your flu vaccine
yes so so as i've said i think the
public has responded magnificently over
the 18 months of the the pandemic in
responding to the the the interventions
that needed to put put in place and they
were incredibly painful but but public
stuck to them and of course coming
forward in droves
to get their their jabs and vaccines in
the
in in the initial stages of vaccine
program i think the important message is
that the booster is not some sort of
add-on it's a really critical part of
maintaining immunity and if we don't
maintain that level of immunity then yes
we will see uh infections translate into
more hospital admissions and more
pressure unfortunately more debt so so
society's has opened up and and that's
great news but people shouldn't get
complacent and shouldn't forget that
there's still a pandemic there and that
public spiritedness of coming forward
and doing your bit for society i think
absolutely we need that spirit um
on on gps gps um you know are extremely
busy as society works up again they've
played an absolutely fantastic role in
the vaccine program and they will
continue to do so but of course our
strategy throughout has been to ensure
that there are as many routes as
possible to get a vaccine so we've
expanded the community pharmacy programs
you get it through your community
pharmacy
we have uh put in place vaccination
centers we've had pop-ups as you've said
and what we've learned
through the initial stage of the vaccine
program and carrying that onto the
booster program is for many people
having a vaccine center which is close
to them is really important and so we
have worked with local communities with
local government with local public
health officials to really identify
where it is to best place those vaccine
centers so that people can access them
easily and we will continue to do that
uh because that we know uh combined with
that public spiritedness is is the way
to get as many people vaccinated as
possible
perhaps
just just add to that so absolutely a
huge thank you to gps but dr steepe he's
actually his primary care and all the
other volunteers that have come in to do
vaccinations through the pandomic um i
just wanted to sort of add perhaps some
clarity because i think from a public
perspective the idea of waning and then
promoting a vaccine can sound a little
counter-intuitive so just to be really
clear the evidence to date shows that uh
the vaccines all three vaccines that
we've been using are around 90 effective
in preventing deaths
up to five months we know that and
obviously jcvi will continue to monitor
that and we publish regularly on it so i
think it's a really important message
out there but exactly
as professor powers has said we we need
to maintain that level
of vaccination as we go forward that's
an important one the second point is
though that vaccination is really good
at preventing serious illness
hospitalizations and deaths it is not
necessarily preventing you getting
infection and this is quite important
because one of the key messages here is
both about vaccinations whether it be
flu or covid but actually our rate the
reproduction rate is hovering somewhere
between 0.9 and 1.1 now when it's
sitting over one those rates will
continue upwards if we just tip it the
other way it will start coming downward
so actually quite small behavioral
changes in all of us would bring that
down so there's a message also to those
who are vaccinated
don't think not to wear a face covering
put a face covering on you may be
carrying an infection with you and not
know
it's really important we've got a
natural break if you like coming up
ahead with half term children have had
largely had infection and so if people
adopt those behaviors and we keep the
vaccination rates up and children are
going forward to get their vaccinations
as well over the half term then i think
that our rate can we can all tip it down
uh under one
thank you jenny chris from the times uh
yes that we said you you said you've
concerned you've created a pretty gloomy
picture of winter and you've piloted
some specific things we can do like
getting our booster jabs wearing face
masks getting tested should we be
changing our behavior in any other way i
mean people are socializing they're
going to the office they're going to
parties some apparently planning
christmas parties should we carry on
with all that or should we be having
some second thoughts and to professor
powers um
we're getting a lot of credit for people
who want to have their booster campaigns
they're eligible they're six months old
but they haven't heard anything from the
national booking service they can't look
in online are you saying today you're
going to change that system so that
people can book in automatically online
once they're actual without having to
wait to be asked
thanks chris that
we are
heading back towards normal we're a lot
closer to normal than we were just a few
months ago
but life isn't back to normal i think
everyone can see that because the
pandemic is still there it's here in our
country it's around the world in other
countries it's where they don't have
sadly the the benefit of the vaccines
for example like we do it's a it's a
much much bigger uh challenge
and and i think
people can see that and so when they are
planning and going about their daily
lives there are just all the things that
we can all do i mean of course uh there
are no restrictions anymore and great on
you know whether it's having you know a
party or a wedding or you know going to
the church or a mosque or something
there's none of the restrictions that we
had before
but there are all uh precautions that we
can take and we've talked about some of
them again today about whether it's face
masks if it's enclosed and with
unfamiliar uh people um
being outdoors when you can and of
course that's harder in the winter and
that's why we're worried about the
winter because it is darker outside
earlier it is colder and so there's less
time outdoors and you want to spend more
indoors so take that into account and
and see what you can do the other the
big thing that i think everyone can do
more of
is is really take advantage of that
offer of a free lateral flow test
because we where we've seen that people
are if they're going to a party perhaps
it has relatives there that are elderly
or grandparents uh someone who's
immunocompromised
then it's really important that you take
a lateral flow test they're there not
because you've got symptoms because
you're being you're taking a precaution
and you take that and and that makes
that party and what you're doing
yourself go ahead with it but it just
makes it a lot safer so
there are really a lot of things that we
can do and and if we want to keep and
hold on to the fantastic progress we've
made then we've all got our role to play
i think one of the things that we've all
learned during the pandemic is to be a
little bit more cautious when we're not
feeling well and we might have an
infectious disease that we could pass on
uh and and so i think you know there's a
there's a sort of stoic british attitude
that you carry on regardless are you
going to work even if you you know
you've got a cold or a sniffle uh but i
think what we've all learned is in doing
that we can spread disease
uh so i think there are simple things
that we can do which is just you know
if if you're feeling a bit you know
unwell it feels like you've got a virus
where it's covered or obviously where
it's covered you need to isolate but if
it's not you know maybe
think cautiously about the risk of
spread spreading it on uh and of course
hand washing hand washing is a very
simple effective measure uh for covid
but but for other infectious diseases so
so i think coming out of this pandemic
people are more cautious and understand
the risk of spreading infectious disease
more and i for one hope that we will
carry on those behaviors on the on the
vaccine and the booster rollout so if i
if i give you the the breakdown of the
figures uh we
eligibility the numbers eligible change
every day of course as more people come
into that uh that eligibility criteria
but but roughly around 8 million people
have become eligible of which as you've
heard four million have been jabbed uh
to date with their boosters there's a
around a couple of million who are being
invited this week so we'll hopefully be
we coming forward in the next few weeks
and there's about half a million five
hundred thousand who we go to directly
such as residents of care homes who
don't get invited in through those
systems so that leaves about one and a
half million uh who uh have been invited
some of them might have been invited
very recently who still need to come
forward so so for those people who've
had the invite already and haven't come
forward please do come forward we have
the capacity uh as the secretary of
state says we've got we've got the jabs
we need your arms to put the jabs into
and of course for those who are coming
forward uh who are getting their invites
this week and in weeks to come don't
delay uh and to make it easier as
secretary of state said uh if a week
after you become eligible you haven't
heard from us then you can go on to the
national booking system
and you can book yourself and that's
exactly what we did if you remember
during the initial rollout where we
targeted people by invitation but then
we
offered um the national booking system
out to people so they could boot
directly so that for those that for
whatever reason haven't heard uh have
the opportunity to just go on and book
themselves
thanks steve and then finally uh jason
from the mail
thanks you seem to be telling us that uh
after a summer off we need to start
concentrating on this again are you
saying that in bold terms that if we
don't get our boosters if we don't take
a bit more care over who we see indoors
uh this winter we are more likely to
face restrictions in the next few months
dr harris you've talked about immunity
waning i don't think it's well
understood
if somebody is
uh say 80 years old and they had their
estrogenic hijab in january how much is
it weighing by now
and just finally the the white house has
said today they're going to start
jabbing children as young as five could
we do that here
okay uh thank you look on um
i think everyone understands that in the
summer
it's it's um
less attractive conditions for whether
it's covered or or flu yeah the we could
be outdoors more it doesn't like the
warm weather and things and and that's
one of the things that clearly helped us
uh during the summer
alongside the vaccinations and some of
the other things we've been talking
about a moment ago
the winter is is it we've always made it
clear it is a more challenging period it
is normally with other viruses so even
remember the pre-covered days it might
be hard to remember them now but for
those of us that do that you know
whether it's flu norovirus and others
they they love the winter for these kind
of virus they love that kind of weather
and so we expected it to be more
challenging as we head into the winter
that's why we set out the plan around
the nhs our social care system and all
the extra support more than normal that
they get over winter but to answer your
question you very specifically uh jason
that you said you know are we am i
saying that if we don't do our bit get
vaccinated you know all those behavioral
changes that that we can make that we
are more likely to face restrictions as
we head
into winter then i am saying that i
think we've been really clear that we've
all got a role to play
you know if people if not enough people
get their booster jobs if if not enough
of those people that were eligible for
the original offer the five million i've
talked about that remain unvaccinated if
they don't come forward if people you
don't wear masks when when they really
should in a really crowded place with
lots of people uh that they that they
you don't normally hang out with if
they're not washing their hands and
stuff it's gonna hit us all and it would
of course make it more likely we're
going to have more restrictions now we
want to avoid those we've set out what
those restrictions might look like we've
set out the plan b restrictions for
example and we all
want to avoid those so we've all got our
role to play we can do it but we've
already done it that's a good thing we
know what to do and how to do it we've
just got to play our part and so if
you're invited for a vaccination
then please take it up please please
we've got plenty of vaccines
and we just need people uh to come
forward and play their part to help us
to keep
you defeating this virus and and and
going ahead uh and getting more and more
back to normal each day
i think i will leave it there
the recovery should i just like oh the
on the childhood vaccination question um
do you want to answer and i think
vaccine effectiveness wasn't it
an important point for for people to
think about is whether the data that
they hear is about getting an infection
which may not be significant and uh
serious serious disease hospitalization
and death and obviously what we've seen
is the effectiveness of vaccines doing
that and they continue to do that so
obviously an eight-year-old or 65 year
old will have different underlying
conditions but for uh somebody over 65
who's had an astrazeneca vaccine has had
two doses
it there our current evidence suggests
that just under 80 percent vaccine
effectiveness in protecting against
hospitalization that is a brilliant
vaccine so if we have that for all of
the vaccines that we use that's very
very good so i think there's a key
message there that's at five months now
that doesn't mean that we're not seeing
some drop off in that as we go forward
which is exactly why we have the vaccine
booster program put in but people
shouldn't think that their coverage if
you like from that their protection
suddenly goes over a cliff edge at five
months and one day or six months in one
day it doesn't but it will wane and um
and the booster will actually boost
people relatively quickly compared to
the first dose um in relation to to
children obviously those questions go to
jcvi they look at all different age
groups all the time uh transmission from
younger children has been considerably
less and what we have seen in recent
weeks obviously is the um 11 to 14 year
olds a young teenage group that's the
predominant one so the the balance of
risk and benefit will be different for
younger children and that's what jcv i
look at yeah thank you jenny that we're
gonna
look i was told not to take any more
questions but i will ignore that advice
that i had and take one more well that's
pretty kind uh two more
that's it please um
can i just ask that a lot of this press
conference has been couched in terms of
it's up to the public to come forward
for jabs but uh immune compromised
groups have been saying that um
people who really really want their
third job at the booster job the third
job um only 40 of them have even had the
uh invite to actually get them you've
got people with blood cancer turning up
at um drop in vaccination centers
basically begging to get third jab and a
lot of people who've got kids in school
you know over 12 are saying that they
really really want their kids to get a
job that their jobs are simply not there
and at the same time the jcvi has yet to
decide whether or not 16 or 17 year olds
are going to get a second job this is
nearly 12 weeks after the first chaps
is there also more the government could
be doing
um there is yes and we are we we are
doing more um
set some of those uh actions out today
so for example you mentioned access for
for children and that's why we're
standing at the vaccination centers
during half dome and beyond half time
actually to give uh parents uh more
choice there's always more that we can
do of course there is it's uh
there's a there's a lot for the
the government to do we've got to keep
playing our part whether it's the
central government it's the nhs and
others and we will absolutely do that
always looking to see how we can improve
access uh for example to vaccines in
particular you've also mentioned another
really important point which is the
immunocompromised and
and and people will know that a few
weeks back uh on the advice of jcvi uh
that uh there is a recommendation that
all those that are immunocompromised
that that they
get access to or given a third dose so i
want to distinguish that between a a
booster dose it is a third dose but it's
a it's it's it's it's probably a third
dose rather than a boost and uh
eligible people uh have been contacted
and are still some still being contacted
either by their gp the consultant the
hospital
there are some people by the way that
are
they are
immunocompromised but they might not
be eligible at this point and that might
be because of the treatment that they're
receiving so uh the the treatment for
any particular condition that they might
have for example a cancer condition that
it
you have to wait really for the advice
of your clinician to see when's the
right time to get it so there are some
people that are waiting but that's
because of the advice of their clinician
the other thing i i think is again it's
worth highlighting is the news that
we've announced today is really relevant
to immunocompromise then that is the new
treatments the new treatments the two
new antivirals that we're one of the few
countries in the world that have
procured them as soon as we get uh
approval from mhra for those we'll be
able to deploy them on the priority
groups the those that are most at risk
and that of course your top of that list
are going to be people that are
immunocompromised so it really gives us
a a new tool uh to to to help and and
treat but especially those that couldn't
benefit uh from uh the vaccine
protection itself and it gives a new way
to to try and help
and then final question sebastian thank
you very much and thank you for the
question um mr jared is there a
difference here between what you're
telling people to do and the behavior of
some senior public figures for example
first paris just said we should be in a
situation of wearing masks in tight
indoor spaces ensure there is
ventilation um in the house of commons
today the benches were completely packed
nobody on the conservative side was
wearing a mask and one of your miniscule
colleagues said that he was planning a
christmas party which seems to go
against the kind of advice we're being
given so isn't there a slight difference
between your telling the public to do
one thing and acting differently
yourself i think i think uh said that is
a very fair point and think that we as i
say we've all got our role to play in
this and uh and we the people standing
up on this stage we play our sort of uh
let's say our our public roles and you
know as a secretary of state and so when
the nhs has had the head of aksa we've
got big roles played but we also have a
role uh to play and set an example as as
private individuals uh as well i think
that's a very fair point and i'm sure a
lot of people would have heard you thank
you all very much thank you
there we are that's sajid javid's first
downing street uh press conference uh
certainly coveted press conference this
pandemic is not over he said the vaccine
has weakened the link between cases and
hospital admissions and deaths but not
broken it uh there's still a threat but
the government he said and here's the
point would not be implementing uh plan
b
at this point he said uh but he warned
cases could go as high as a hundred
thousand a day
and he said would do what it takes to
protect the nhs from being overwhelmed
jenny harris
of the uk health security agency said
the numbers
are going in the wrong direction stephen
powers of the nhs said the nhs is under
considerable pressure interestingly
sajid javid said we don't think the
pressures on the nhs are unsustainable
and it was really a call to the public
to play its part the over 50s to get
booster jabs
and he said if we play our part we can
give ourselves the best possible chance
of getting through the winter and
enjoying christmas with our loved ones
let's bring in our political editor
beth rigby and beth i mean basically
that was the point wasn't it saying to
the public if you do the right thing you
can enjoy christmas it's down to you if
you don't then we could get
uh more
restrictive measures
yes mark that was the fast cavit press
conference since september the 14th five
weeks ago when the prime minister
announced that winter plan
uh that plan b
if necessary and then
the fears over covered if you like
dropped away it wasn't discussed um
there hasn't been face mask wearing in
the commons uh particularly for example
there hasn't been any mandatory face
mask wearing at all uh there hasn't been
any requirements for social distance in
all of those rules and that guidance
that we live for and by for so long had
fallen away and i think really my
takeaway from that press conference is
covid is back
it is a risk it's a growing risk the
government are clearly worried about it
the nhs are talking about uh rising
cases rising
admissions and i really think that the
message there
from the secretary of state and he said
it a number of times was that not at
this time are we going to implement plan
b but everyone needs to do and i quote
him their bit to prevent that from
happening
he said quite clearly in that press
conference you need to go and get jab
not just to save lives but and i quote
him to protect our freedoms jason grows
from the daily mail the political editor
explicitly asked there if we if we don't
get our boosters uh if we don't follow
some of your recommendations
does that mean that we're going to have
to face further restrictions
and this health secretary there was
quite clear when he said
yes you are everyone needs to do their
bit otherwise further restrictions are
coming down the line and it was
interesting that they dusted off some of
the old
guidance and rules so suddenly we've
been asked again to think about meeting
outside we're being asked to put on face
masks at our discretion uh when we're in
crowded or not ventilated
areas and then also here there was a big
play there and a press from him about
lateral flow testing take a lateral
flotus before you go in to your
christmas party for example take a
lateral flow test before you're going to
meet people stephen powers said if
you've got a colder virus
think about not meeting people so what
the government are doing really is
they're trying to push the
responsibility
back on to the individual to ask all of
us to make these uh minor micro
decisions in our lives uh the first and
foremost being get the vaccination get
the boosters if you haven't but the
warning there is quite clear that if the
case numbers keep going up and the
hospitalizations rise then plan b will
be enacted and we're going to have to
have a far more restrictive regime again
in how we live okay beth thank you very
much indeed
well in a moment i'm going to be talking
to the shadow health secretary jonathan
ashworth but first let's hear some of
what the health secretary sergey javid
had to say about the threat facing us as
we head into winter
cases are rising
and yesterday we reported forty three
thousand seven hundred and thirty eight
new cases across the uk
up sixteen percent from the previous
week
and they could go yet as high as a
hundred thousand a day
we're also seeing greater pressure on
the nhs
across the uk
we're now approaching 1 000
hospitalizations per day
the nhs is performing with distinction
and i'd like to thank everyone who's
working so hard to keep us safe
and we'll do what it takes
to make sure that this pressure doesn't
become unsustainable and that we don't
allow the nhs to become overwhelmed
deaths remain mercifully low
but they are still sadly over 100 a day
this pandemic is not over
thanks to the vaccination program
yes the the link between cases and
hospitalizations and deaths has
significantly weakened
but it's not broken
so we must all remember
that this virus will be with us for the
long term
and that it remains a threat
a threat to our loved ones and a threat
to the progress that we've made in
getting our nation closer to normal life
we're looking closely at the data
and we won't be implementing our plan b
of contingency measures at this point
but we'll be staying vigilant preparing
for all eventualities while
strengthening our vital defenses that
can help us fight back against this
virus
i'm pleased to announce that we have
signed two landmark deals
securing hundreds of thousands of doses
of two new antivirals from pfizer
and from merck sharp dome
these antivirals have the potential to
speed up recovery time and to stop
infections from progressing
if these treatments get mhra approval
then we can provide some of the most
vulnerable patients with vital
protection this summer and i want to
deploy them as quickly as possible
sanji javid there as i said uh i'm
joined now by the shadow health
secretary jonathan ashwa thank you for
being with us so uh what did you make of
what the health secretary had to say
i thought it was a rather complacent
presentation frankly
we're in a very serious situation now
with the levels of covid infections in
the community which is obviously
knocking on to hospitalizations and
sadly deaths
government ministers have talked about
our wall of defense being vaccination
well
our wall of defense is beginning to
crumble because the booster program is
stalling on current trends we won't
complete that program until spring of
next year that's simply unacceptable
we've only vaccinated around 15 percent
of our young people and of course the
infections are concentrated at the
moment in in school children i think
over the last three weeks we've seen
around 10 000 infections a day
amongst children of course the third
doses for the immunosuppressed is
stalling and charities have called it uh
chaotic
and the flu vaccine which we also need
to really ramp up he's running at around
36
for over 65s
i wanted to hear from ministers how they
were going to get a grip of this
stalling vaccination program well to be
fair
to be fair he said they were going to
accelerate uh the booster program for
the elderly and the vulnerable i mean
what would labour be doing that the
government isn't sort of rushing to
another lockdown
most certainly not nobody wants to go
back to the dark days of lockdown so nor
do we want to see
the prime minister impose lockdowns on
places like bolton burnley berry and
lester my own which he did
in the